في ضوء ما قبل الفجر،
تنافر القوة النارية العسكرية يملأ
الهواء، انفجارات واردة،
نيران صادرة، بينما تحاول إحدى
وحدات المشاة الهجومية الأوكرانية التابعة للواء الميكانيكي 47
استعادة الخنادق في
أديفا التي استولت عليها
القوات الروسية، نحتاج إلى طائرات بدون طيار، نحتاج إلى طائرات بدون طيار،
يقول قائد الشركة  OLG يصور بكاميرا
GoPro الخاصة به، الأوغاد يجلسون في
خط الأشجار ويطلقون النار علينا،
يشرح في مقابلة نادرة أن
المخرج السابق الذي سجنه الروس في عام
2014 لمدة 5 سنوات، أخبرني عن
مهمة الشهر الماضي في ما أصبح
أحد أهم المواقع  على
الجبهة الشرقية، كان هدفي هو أن يشاهد الناس
هذا ويعرفوا كيف تبدو هذه الحرب حقًا
لأنه من المهم جدًا
تسجيلها حتى يعرف الناس الآن
ويعرفوا لاحقًا ما هي الحرب القاسية والرهيبة التي
خاضها أحد قواته.
ضربوا بإزالة درعه الجسدي ليكشفوا عن
ثقب رصاصة أثناء تطبيق ختم الشطرنج،
يواجه الفريق مشاكل أكبر على
أيديهم، بطة الدبابة قادمة نعم واحد منهم
ثم يبدأ الجدار من السماء
بدون طيار بدون طيار fpv يبكي جنديًا
أنا  شاهد ذلك وهو يصرخ مرة أخرى
بعد دقائق، أصيب جندي آخر
هذه المرة بشظية في
ساقيه أثناء حديثه في الراديو وهو
يتحدث عن قواته المصابة، كما
أصيب OLG لكنه لم يدرك لبضع
لحظات أن هناك ثقبًا صغيرًا أرى
الدم فيك.  يقول إعادة النزيف إن
المظلة الأنثوية التي تم ترقيعها بسرعة تظل OLG
مركزة ومتماسكة
حتى سمعوا فجأة قعقعة
الدبابات التي تحاول وحدة OLG دفن
نفسها في الأرض بينما يقود أحدهم
صرخات المسعفة نحن محاصرون والدبابات
تطلق النار علينا حوالي 40  طن من
الرعب قريب جدًا من الأرض
تهتز لقطات طائرة بدون طيار التقطها
الجيش الأوكراني تظهر أربع
دبابات روسية تطلق النار على خط الأشجار
المتمركز في تلك الأشجار، وهي عبارة عن ثلاث
مجموعات هجومية أوكرانية في خنادق
منتشرة على مسافة كيلومتر واحد
في المنتصف.  الوحيدون الذين تم
إنقاذهم، فشلنا في الحفاظ على مواقعنا
واضطررنا إلى التراجع، تعرضنا لإصابات لكننا
نجونا، لكن المجموعتين الأخريين تم
تدميرهما بالكامل تقريبًا، وهذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يفشل فيها o في مهمة كقائد خلال
العامين تقريبًا اللذين كان
يقاتل فيهما  أخبرني الرجل البالغ من العمر 47 عامًا أنه
يريد أن يعرف العالم الحقيقة على
خط المواجهة، وهي الحرب التي يعود إليها هذا الأب لأربعة أطفال
هذا الأسبوع